[Music]
our brigade belonged to the sixth corps
of lieutenant general essen ii
[Music]
in nesfish we lived splendidly not
thinking about the french few of our
officers preoccupied themselves with
politics we occasionally heard political
news from local newspapers but quickly
forgot about it in the clatter of our
carefree daily life
only one man
n one of our non-commissioned officers
an intelligent man who read both the
scripture and the moscow newspapers was
horrified by napoleon
tormented by the ghosts of his
imagination he began to preach to us
that the antichrist apollyon or napoleon
had brought together great evil forces
near warsaw for no other purpose but to
destroy our mother russia that with the
help of satan beelzebub the enemy would
inevitably capture moscow and conquer
the entire russian nation and soon
thereafter the world would face
judgement day
we
laughed at such absurdities which
greatly annoyed n who called us godless
constantly imbibing tobacco he did his
best to persuade us and kept referring
to the ninth chapter of revelations
which he said described napoleon as the
leader of the dreaded army with the
lion's teeth breastplates of iron and
scorpion's tails
afterwards we were quite surprised when
the french did invade russia and
occupied moscow
france under napoleon was stronger than
russia his vast army stood at our very
frontiers
most people were convinced of the
invincibility of napoleon what kind of a
russian would not have been terrified to
see this invincible colossus ready to
invade his beloved motherland
such emotional anguish could certainly
produce visions and imaginary
revelations
which were then partially confirmed by
subsequent events
we celebrated new year's eve 1811 with
dances
indulging ourselves with sweet
sentimentality under a pleasant haze of
intoxication older officers were
frightened of napoleon seeing him as a
terrible conqueror the new attila
while we the young happily frolicked
under cupid's gaze
and then our lives were interrupted by
the thunderous roar of war
we were told to prepare for a campaign
alas
farewell our sweet paniance
if only napoleon knew how spirited and
eager the russians were to fight his
forces
then he would not have entertained the
futile hope of conquering russia
the french forces which had been
accustomed to victories were at least
twice as large as ours while what can be
said about their leader if not that the
history of modern times has never seen
anyone like him with good fortune or the
ability to win
napoleon could be defeated only with his
own weapon to adopt his political system
and the manner of waging war and so the
weaker side had to turn to a military
stratagem
to retreat step by step in front of a
stronger enemy lure him deeper and
deeper into the woods and marshes where
the lack of supplies exhaustion from
prolonged marches and harshness of
climate would have so weakened him that
the weaker side could dare attacking the
defenseless enemy
our commander-in-chief was determined to
repulse enemy attacks from the northern
direction so as to allow for an
unimpeded union with the second army it
seemed therefore that he was ready to
give battle
at dawn we broke camp the soldiers
crossed themselves to ensure a good
start and moved forward with resolution
as soon as we reached the ostrov road we
heard the sound of gunfire at some
distance
our advanced guard was already in action
the closer we came to the battlefield
marching along the side of the main road
the clearer we heard the sound of
gunfire
the sense of a nearby battle
the first one in my life
took over
this video was sponsored by magellan tv
question why is christmas day on
december 25th a it was the same day as
the roman festival for soul invictus b
it was nine months after jesus supposed
day of conception or c it was chosen to
weaken the pagan festival of mithra
and the answer is we don't know all
three are possible and so my
recommendation this week is one of
magellan's new documentaries which they
add every week the american saint nick
of world war ii is a heartwarming tale
of optimism in the diarist circumstances
the return of christmas cheer to an
occupied small town in luxembourg by
american troops a great historical
christmas treat and of course magellan
have more than 3 000 other documentaries
to check out too and this christmas
voices of the past viewers can take
advantage of a special holiday offer buy
one get one free gift cards for an
annual membership by clicking on the
link in the description
thanks
[Music]
about one vester from the battlefield we
were ordered to stop and prepare for
battle
infantry men began loading their muskets
and the rattle of ramrod soon filled the
air artillery men prepared ammunition
while officers drew their swords
i still had no clear idea about what a
battle was
i believed that everybody converging on
a battlefield was destined to perish
that each cannonball or bullet would
invariably kill or wound a man and
therefore i would probably not survive
this fight but seeing how bravely
everyone around me marched onwards i had
no other choice but to follow their
example
passing by me our artillery brigade
commander saw me sitting quietly on a
gun carriage and said
keep resting lad the real work will soon
begin
these were his last words
because as soon as he reached the
battlefield an enemy cannonball
shattered his chest and traversing
through it
melted both his heart and gold coins
that were inside his pocket
when the cannonballs began to whistle
above our heads and cut men from our
ranks the infantry rushed forward while
the artillery trotted behind the
skirmishers scattered in brushwood
batteries were set up and the fight
ensued
the enemy batteries engaged us from
three sides their cannonballs hopped all
around us like rabbits dead soldiers lay
on the road one of them had his head
torn off another had his stomach ripped
apart while a third lay without legs
my heart convulsed at their sight and an
uncomfortable feeling took over i became
faint-hearted and felt weakness in my
knees
veteran soldiers observe that fear
disturbs the heart of a young soldier
only before a battle begins because his
thoughts still consider the deathly
horrors that leave a bad impression
but once he's in the midst of a battle
fear is eclipsed by rage
as he puts his life in danger a soldier
ceases to be an observer and becomes an
active participant
and death ceases to frighten him
his heart fills with blood and he
disregards danger turning into a
seemingly insensitive being
i was in such a condition when our
cannons were ordered to deploy the
designated spot suddenly cannonballs
began to whistle by me one of them hit a
horse artillery man while another
sheared off a canonies legs together
with his cartridge pouch he fell in
front of me and wretchedly cried
save me your honor moments earlier i had
shuddered at seeing the dead but i
became callous and simply ordered my men
to drag him to the side so he did not
interfere with our operations
in the deafening din of canadian
gunpowder i kept losing my concentration
the enemy cannonballs mercilessly
ravaged the infantry behind me so i
decided to repay them by turning my fire
against the enemy columns that had been
moving forward along the main road and
fired ricochet shots so successfully
that they immediately disordered the
enemy infantry and forced it to halt
meanwhile my gunners had ran out of
ammunition i took a horse and galloped
to find our company commander to ask him
for a new cannon and ammunition
but alas i was astounded by the
condition of our artillery on the right
side of the road several guns were
scattered around damaged or overturned
and dead gunners and horses lay among
them
eventually i found our lieutenant
colonel amidst great commotion
upon seeing me he asked
you are still alive i replied as you can
see just give me a gun and ammunition
what else lad he continued our entire
company is shattered gaurianov is
captured schlippenbach and bryco have
lost their legs
the lieutenant colonel then approached
count ostermann and began to report to
him that the company lost many men
killed and that there were quite a few
damaged cannon that could no longer be
employed what will you command of me
your grace he finally inquired
the count sniffing tobacco replied
curtly
fire from the cannon that is still
functional
meanwhile someone informed the count
that the enemy cannonballs claimed many
lives in the infantry and suggested
moving them back to safety
no
hold ground and die
the count sternly replied
a third aide soon approached and wanted
to say something to the count when a
cannonball ripped off his hand
which flew by the count
take care of him said the count
and turned his horse
the unshakable presence of mind in a
commander at a moment when everything
was in disarray all around him was a
genuine manifestation of the russian
character
looking at him we all gained courage
from his example and returned to our
places
ready
to die
[Music]
i was pleased to see the damage my
cannon calls the enemy naturally this is
the only time one is allowed to enjoy
the evil one inflicts on fellow humans
who willingly or not had become our
enemies
i diligently aimed the cannon for
another salvo and just as i stepped back
to see how well the sight was set an
enemy cannonball suddenly appeared as a
black dot out of dense smoke and flew
towards me
it was supposed to be a death blow but
my inner sense or self-preservation
instinct pushed me back towards the gun
i stumbled and the cannibal knocked me
over soldiers rushed to me and placing
me on their muskets carried me behind
the front line
i thought that i had my legs blown off
and dared not look at them
i felt my right leg might be shattered
around my foot area but i could still
use my left leg so i found a thick
branch to prop myself up and standing up
with some difficulty i slowly moved
towards the road
throughout this journey i did not dare
to look at my right leg and struggled to
drag it along yet pain was intensifying
and soon it spread along my entire leg
i felt a burning sensation as if i was
on fire reaching our supply train i
found our brigade treasurer who advised
me to get immediately into a hearse that
was taking the wounded to tolmin our
divisional officer
this poor lad had his right arm ripped
off above the elbow climbing onto the
hearse i finally decided to look at my
foot and was thrilled to see that only
the rear side of my boot was broken and
burnt as if by fire the cannonball would
have certainly severed my leg if not for
my instinct that saved me
our company suffered considerable losses
in this battle
we lost up to 60 cannoneers and some 30
horses
four cannons had their carriages and
wheels damaged one officer was captured
and three wounded
the polish lancers formed by prince
rajavue inflicted severe damage to us
but the prince himself was wounded
during the attack when he was shot in
the leg by al canister
on the eve of war when we were quartered
in nezvish the prince was a frequent
visitor at our camp
we even visited his estate to attend two
magnificent balls that he had organized
who would have thought that
circumstances would drive us apart
turn us into enemies and compel us to
inflict such harm on each other
[Music]
on the 14th of july the town's surgeons
showed up as promised and this time they
brought their instruments with them
at that moment i found them more
terrifying than the french cavalry
the lead surgeon's blue coat powdered
wig and long nose appeared to me as
nightmares for several nights in a row
the surgeon asked well how are you
i was terrified and hiding my leg i
replied
i am doing well sir there is no need to
cut me
let us see he replied and i did not dare
to resist my deformed heel was swollen
all blue and seemed to be covered by the
antonov fire the surgeons in glasses
carefully examined and touched it then
talked among themselves in latin
the powdered wig seemed undecided
whether to cut my leg or not
i confess that at that moment the
esteemed surgeon standing with his
curved knife in front of me seemed to be
more terrifying than napoleon
i could read the sentence of life or
death on his wrinkly forehead since i
did not think my weak health would allow
me to survive the operation
fortunately because of the latin's
unanimous verdict the curved knife was
set aside and instead a small pen knife
appeared in front of me as i was turned
over the surgeons grabbed my leg tight
and suddenly struck my swollen heel with
a knife
i screamed with pain but then felt
relieved the wound was full of thickened
blood that accumulated under the skin
and its bluish hue looked like the anton
of fire which raised the surgeon's
suspicion
thus
my foot was spared after being so close
to being severed from my body
i was thrilled i was not left disabled
i raved about treachery and traitors and
my feverish mind imagined the abominable
napoleon as a supernatural being
protected by infernal forces i had
visions of the red hussars in
bare-skinned hats galloping straight at
me with their swords drawn
as well as of skinny tanned italian
skirmishers finding their way through
brushwood like hyenas and aiming their
deadly weapons at me
thus the horrors i experienced before
seemed now
so much livelier
i had to cover my face with my hands so
as to avoid seeing these ghosts
shuddering at imagining the demise of
russia
suffering from high fever
i could not make any observations
for several days
[Music]
after the retreat which lasted nearly
two months our troops needed rest and
fresh food
rumors claimed that the enemy army was
suffering deficiencies in everything and
was exhausted from never-ending marches
through devastated country
such news
thrilled us the rumors claimed that
there was unrest in napoleon's army that
his troops were no longer willing to
march any deeper into the land of the
scythians
but the haughtiness and arrogance of the
captured frenchmen certainly didn't
confirm it
they were far from being discouraged and
instead told us that we would all soon
suffer the fate of falling into
captivity
such was their confidence in the
invincibility
of napoleon
on the 1st of august i returned to my
company i was partially recovered from
my wound which had not fully healed yet
my leg was wrapped in bandages and i had
to use crutches to move around i felt
awkward everywhere suffered from pain
and as people say all of this was not to
my liking
on the 2nd of august our troops marched
forward 15 verses deploying in a valley
in front of caspelia lake
the fields were full of ripe grain that
was so tall it reached above soldiers
wastes and we felt pity knowing that
this scenic place would be trampled by
soldiers pitching camp thereby
eradicating the fruits of peasants hard
labor
the 5th of august proved to be a fateful
day for the city and bloody for the
contending armies
the artillery fire from both sides was
murderous the battle reached its climax
during the evening the cumulative
horrors of fighting turned indescribable
hundreds of cannonballs and grenades
whistled through the air and burst one
after another the air above the city
darkened from smoke the earth groaned
and it seemed that it disgorged hellish
fires from deep inside
death itself struggled to consume all of
its victims
the enemy grenades ignited fires inside
the city which embodied a new hellish
vision for us
a battle in the midst of raging fire
as we stood on the bank of the river
looking at the blazing city an
instinctive tremor of the heart revealed
to us that we were still too weak to
face our powerful enemy
from there on the french pursuit eased
off as the most recent fights had cooled
their arda
besides it was said that napoleon was
still at smolensk pondering what to do
next
the dust and heat were intolerable for
several verses back and forth one could
not see anything but artillery and
baggage trains moving in dense clouds of
dust that kept rising to the sky
we walked as if shrouded in fog the sun
seemed purple and neither the greenery
by the side of the road nor the paint on
the gun carriages could be discerned
soldiers were covered from head to toe
in grey dust and our faces and hands
were black from dust and sweat
as the heat tormented us with thirst we
couldn't find any refreshments
in such miserable conditions we happened
to pass by a crowd of french prisoners
who had been captured in the last battle
and were happy to see us hastily
retreating
they mockingly told us that we would not
get away from napoleon because they now
made up the vanguard of his army
i must admit that our soldiers became
very disheartened after the battle at
smelensk
the blood that had been shed in the
ruins of smolensk all the effort made to
resist the enemy as well as retreating
on the moscow road into the depths of
russia itself had made each and every
one of us feel powerless against our
terrible conqueror
burning villagers were behind and all
around us announcing the approaching
french troops
the cossacks destroyed everything that
was left behind following the passage of
our troops so that the enemy only found
baron and desolate land everywhere
thus desperate russia
tormented her own womb
on the 22nd of august our troops passed
through the village of borudino
it was here that we first saw the
russian peasants armed with pikes and
muskets which they barely knew how to
hold
the russians did not have sufficient
forces we had up to one hundred and
fifteen thousand regular troops seven
thousand cossacks ten thousand apple
chenier and 640 guns
the french had 190 000 of their best
troops and up to a thousand guns however
our disparity in numbers was evened out
by our love for the fatherland and our
thirst for vengeance
remembering the former glory of
victorious russian arms each soldier
burned with impatience to engage the
enemy so that their blood could wash
away the humiliation that all of us had
suffered
the french had also prepared for battle
except that they were not inspired by a
love for their fatherland but only by
their ravenousness for plunder and glory
of conquest
they had gone too far into russia and
sought victory to save themselves as
well as to preserve the honor of their
arms
they had suffered great hardships
experiencing hitherto unheard of
deprivation if defeated they faced
inevitable destruction but if they
emerged victorious
pleasant prospects flattered their
ambition
moscow lay open before them beyond the
battlefield
thus the fate of napoleon's grand army
would be decided on the field of
borradino
[Music]
this army was supported by almost all of
europe with the french germans italians
spaniards poles all ready to follow any
whims of that extraordinary man and
either win
or die
and die
they did
the day of preparation for the terrible
battle seemed fleeting the complete
silence that reigned in both armies was
a harbinger of impending horrors
how many thousands of future victims of
human enmity still enjoyed life that day
only to turn to dust the following
thus a man is destined to remain the
plaything of passions to reach for the
heavens with his mind
and to disappear in earthly irrelevance
the sun shone brightly and glided its
golden rays over the fatal steel of our
bayonets and muskets it sparkled with
brilliant light on the copper of our
guns
everything was getting ready for
bloodshed on the morrow
in short
three hundred thousand men from both
armies
were preparing for the great
terrible day
as the sun rose at dawn numerous guns
howitzers and liquids erupted into a
ferocious cannonade all along the line
between the left flank and the center
the cannon fire was so frequent that
there were no lulls in the explosions
that continued incessantly resembling a
thunder and producing a man-made
earthquake
thick clouds of smoke curling around the
batteries ascended to heaven and soon
obscured the sun which became veiled in
a bloody shroud as if affected by human
rage and ferocity
standing on the right flank i long
remained a quiet spectator of this
spectacle and stood silently next to my
gun
expecting orders to join the battle at
any moment
the enemy cannonballs reached us in
leaps and bounds or rolling on the
ground
shells exploded in the air scattering
numerous splinters while making a
terrifying noise
the crimson sun having dipped its last
ray of light in the blood of so many
dead
disappeared over the horizon as if
shuddering from the terrible slaughter
that unfolded beneath it
darkness descended on the field of death
and the gunpowder smoke and stench
enveloped the vast battlefield in a
heavy mist
thus ended the famous battle of the 26th
of august
despite the enemy's numerical
superiority the russians had never
before fought with such ferocities on
this momentous occasion
they steadfastly endured all the damage
inflicted by cannonballs and bullets
spreading death in the enemy ranks while
suffering equally at their hands
napoleon let us withdraw to majesk
without attempting any pursuit which
once again demonstrated that he had
broken his teeth on us and was seemingly
content with the battlefield that was
left to him to witness the immense
casualties that his forces had suffered
and so on the 30th of august we arrived
at a fortified camp established around
the village of mamanova some 19 verstas
from moscow
picturesque hills crowned with groves
and beautiful manor houses were half
visible above the treetops signaling
that we were already in the environs of
our ancient capital
as we approach the heart of the russian
realm we bowed our heads ashamed to look
at the golden domed mother city that
could not be protected from destruction
some feeble minds embrace the idea of
napoleon's supernatural abilities
he was widely cursed in the churches and
some even claimed that his name was
mentioned in the book of revelation
many russian warriors who loathed the
horrors of death
were becoming physically and mentally
distressed
we expected that there would be a
decisive battle more ferocious even than
borudino
but
circumstances
produced a rather different
and unexpected outcome
[Music]
feelings woken by the sight of the
perishing capital as well as by the
hatred felt towards our enemy excited my
imagination that one morning i
experienced a genuinely patriotic dream
i dreamt that i somehow found myself
disguised as a frenchman in the enemy
camp
i took a pistol out of my pocket and
shot the general from the side the
bullet pierced his chest and the general
fell to the ground
but as he did he turned to face me
and to my grief i saw that it was not
napoleon
it's murat i exclaimed as i was grasped
by officers who would certainly have
shot me if i didn't wake up
meanwhile the headquarters held a
council of war attended by the senior
generals the field marshal made the
decision to withdraw his troops and
abandon moscow to the french
so they could perish there
only field marshal prince kutuzov the
genuine son of russia who suckled on her
breasts could surrender the ancient
capital of the empire without a fight
public opinion would have condemned any
other commander as an apparent traitor
our retreat was conducted in an orderly
fashion but surrounded by dreary silence
approaching the bereaved capital the
mother of all russian cities our
soldiers gazed with broken hearts at
beautiful buildings that were abandoned
to the enemy
the kremlin with its gothic towers the
vast and ancient palaces of the russian
sars and the golden domed ivan the great
about to become silent witnesses to
impending calamities
everything was now sacrificed to the
enemy
and all the while
thousands of russians fled with their
arms in their hands
we passed by the kremlin and entered the
city where we saw misery crying and
despair everywhere
officers began to gather in groups to
discuss what would happen next since
none of us knew what to expect meanwhile
the rank and file under the pretext of
fetching some water slipped into nearby
shops houses and cellars that were left
open as if to treat the passerby
and while there they bid goodbye
in their own manner
to mother moscow
[Music]
by nightfall we approached the village
of panchi about 15 verses from moscow
it was then we saw the fire in the city
it was only the beginning the fire
intensified throughout the night and by
the morning of the 3rd of september a
greater part of the horizon was
enveloped in flames
we involuntarily shuddered with surprise
and horror
the superstitious not comprehending what
was happening before their eyes thought
that the fall of moscow signaled the
fall of russia the triumph of the
antichrist and the impending start of
judgment day
as the sun set my friend figna
approached me
hey brother elia
i want to say goodbye to you i'm going
back to moscow if i do not return within
a week to not consider me alive
he shook my hand and disappeared
his words astounded me as much as the
moscow fire did
after resting on the 3rd of september we
resumed our march
the weather was overcast cold and wet
rather appropriate for the current
situation
for 6 days and 6 nights moscow slowly
died
turning to ashes
the flames that consumed it left an
indelible impression on the minds and
feelings of not only the sons of russia
but the enemy as well
from the moment moscow turned to ash
political upheavals gradually spread on
both continents old and new world
thus in six days the city that grew and
thrived for six centuries
disappeared to soothe the sons of russia
who were distressed by the loss of the
capital the person who was the direct
target of soldiers resentments as the
initiator of this endless retreat and
the cause of our heavy losses decided to
appear in front of the troops
so commander of the first army barclay
de tally passed in front of the lines of
troops and stopping in front of each
regiment made a brief but powerful and
inspiring speech
oftentimes in the midst of extreme
challenges great sacrifices are needed
for great results
it is true that our capital has turned
to ash but you must know that from these
ashes the destruction of the enemy and
all his forces are born
they are nothing but a band of vagabonds
who are hungry for food and plunder
soon we will witness the destruction of
the new charles xii
soon he will try to flee from you faster
than lightning but will only fight death
in the russian realm and his ashes will
be scattered under your feet
the last words were spoken with such
expressiveness and passion that they
seemingly poured into the soldiers
hearts
soldiers quickly recovered their spirits
old veterans with long mustaches
recalled stories of how their
grandfathers had indeed crushed the
swedes at poltava and thought that
napoleon would share charles's fate if
only they would trust completely in
their commander's will and stand firmly
to the last drop of their blood
men no longer grieved for moscow saying
that our tsar could turn any town into a
capital just as peter the great turned
swamps into saint petersburg
by evening music began to play in all
regiments songs could be heard and the
soldier's revelry resumed once more
in hindsight i never felt so good during
the entire campaign
from the 23rd of september to the 5th of
october we lived quietly at the
tarantino camp for almost two weeks
without concerning ourselves with the
french
we were provided with recruits horses
and ammunition sheepskin coats boots and
fed biscuits while the horses received
plenty of oats and hay
we also received triple payments and on
top of it the rank and file was given
five rubles in paper money for the
battle of borradino it was then that
everyone truly went on a bender
peasants from nearby and far away
settlements came to the camp to find
their surviving relatives or fellow
villagers peasant women came daily in
droves bringing goodies to soldiers and
seeking their husbands sons and brothers
i saw many such women driven by militant
patriotism and proclaiming just give us
lords pikes and we will go after the
french ourselves
it seemed that all of russia had
converged spiritually at our camp
as mornings turned cold in october and
cloudy days announced the approach of
the cold winter
officers began building dugouts and wear
coats
fires were constantly maintained and
warming up around them we envisioned the
miserable fate of the french in our cold
climate
there were rumors that the position of
the enemy army was worsening with each
passing day
they had consumed all the supplies
discovered in moscow and had no other
means of procuring new provisions except
by feeding on dead horses
our fourth corps occupied the enemy
bivouacs near the village of dendi
we were startled to see the remains of
horses the french had devoured around
their shelters that were made of various
doors tables etc
we discovered that the french still had
some cereals and peas but lacked bread
and beef
we even came across a beautiful black
cult with a fine pebble-grained leather
breastplate and bells
apparently they were fattening him
instead of veal
we marched in the wake of the french on
the main smellensk road and were
horrified to see that the roadway had
turned into a continuous cemetery as if
a devastating play could pass through
this region every versta we encountered
several dozen corpses of horses and men
with overturned wagons scattered among
them
we saw many frozen horses with their
tender parts removed
we even saw to our amazement one
frenchman lying inside the horse's gut
holding its liver in his hands
apparently intending to devour it
the severe cold had frozen him in this
posture
presenting to us the highest degree of
human misery
some unfortunate french soldiers who
remained on the road were still alive
but so weakened from complete exhaustion
and hunger that they lost their ability
to communicate and only their slight
hand movements indicated they were still
living we found a blonde officer in this
condition in a thin blue uniform and a
three cornered hat sitting under a tree
next to the road
his eyes were half open his head bent to
one side and a deathly pallor covered
his handsome face
he did not respond to our questions
but his right hand moved towards his
heart
it was clear he was about to leave this
world
his eyes suddenly froze
and he died before us
such horrors which we witnessed
throughout our journey after leaving
viasma had a profound and uncomfortable
impact on us
even though the french were our enemies
and had devastated our homeland our
thirst for revenge could not overshadow
our sense of humanity and compassion to
such an extent that we could not
commiserate their hardships
[Music]
i will never forget the night of the
27th of october which we spent in dora
gaboush
we entered the town after nightfall i
deployed cannon by the side of the road
and took quarters in the yard of a house
on the outskirts of town soldiers spent
the night in great misery without tents
warming up by the fire in the open air
as we settle down on frozen ground
covered with snow and ignited a bonfire
in front of the tent i looked around and
saw numerous corpses of men and horses
all around us
dimly lit by the fire
as we had become accustomed to such
sites and had more than once enjoyed a
sound sleep amidst such a cemetery
forgetting all the prejudices of
childhood we paid no attention to it
this time and tried to warm our
stiffened limbs
meanwhile the light of the fire and the
tent which was set up away from the
others attracted wounded and exhausted
frenchmen
the first to approach us was a tall and
skinny german probably a cavalryman but
we could not discern any uniform on him
we noticed that his legs for want of
shoes were wrapped in a sack that the
wily german tied to his knees slowly
moving towards us like a scarecrow
his contorted face took on a joyful
appearance from the wholesome warmth of
the fire especially after we gave him a
stale biscuit that we soaked in hot
water
we asked him about napoleon and as soon
as his name was uttered numerous curses
cursed and damned to be he for eternity
pulled out of the mouth of this poor man
soon after him came another one a true
frenchman in a great coat
he seemed to be more cheerful though
also very fatigued and weak
the tall german stopped cursing napoleon
and probably out of hatred for the
french stood up thanked us and went to
look for another refuge
seeing the frenchman's futile efforts to
gnaw a russian biscuit i asked him if he
would consider eating horse meat
why not he said there are no limits when
it comes to hardship
so i pointed to a nearby horse and
suggested that he might be able to
satisfy his hunger at once
we gave him an axe
i wanted to see what he would do
the frenchman with axe in hand dodded
towards the horse and dropping to his
knees began to strike it with all the
might that he still had
but the corpse had been petrified from
cold
seeing that it was impossible for him to
get any meat the poor man returned to
the fire and laying down the axe he said
very calmly
what else to do
one has to die
and lay down on the ground
when we reached the main road from minsk
to vilna which our unfortunate enemy
used to escape we encountered numerous
overturned wagons corpses of killed or
frozen humans and horses scattered on
and under snow on one occasion my cannon
got stuck in a pothole and almost turned
over i rushed with my cannoneers to hold
it up and was shocked to see that the
wheel was in fact stuck in between the
bones of a frozen corpse once we met two
russian women who with clubs in hand
were escorting about three dozen ragged
and half frozen frenchmen upon seeing
the jubilation of these women as they
led their captive enemies
we couldn't help but laugh
but on the other hand we could not but
feel sorry upon seeing how humiliated
and how disgraced these once proud
conquerors of europe had become
along the way we occasionally stopped at
taverns and were usually treated to
terrible sights inside
ordinarily there was a fire in the
middle of the room and frozen frenchmen
lay all around it on the floor
those closest to the fire were still
moving
but the rest
were all dead
their bodies distorted and faces
disfigured
such were the calamities that befell
napoleon's great army
on the 10th of december our artillery
stopped at the village of paradamino
about 15 verses from vilna
meanwhile as the forces of admiral
chichigov and count wittgenstein as well
as other flying detachments drove the
enemy finally out of russia and pursued
his survivors all the way to the vestula
the main army of the field marshal took
up winter quarters around vilna
thus peace and order were once again
restored and russia had risen from her
deathbed
while devastation was considerable and
especially felt by the poor villagers
such wounds healed little by little and
the losses were soon recouped through
hard work and help from the government
thus napoleon's army of half a million
men
was destroyed with which he fancied to
conquer russia
fifty generals and one hundred thousand
soldiers ended up prisoners of war as if
to ensure that no future european nation
even in alliance with others would dare
to attempt another invasion like this
you